Hi, I'm Erik Voss and now that Game of Thrones Season 7 is complete
We're left wondering where things are headed for the final season.
Based on some clues from this past season and some things set up in the books
And my general understanding of how stories are plotted based off of my own crazy writing
I got some hot predictions, and I don't mean to brag, but right after season 6 ended
I did one of these predictions videos for season 7 which was surprisingly accurate.
I'm gonna call it here.
I predict that by the end of season 7. We're gonna see the White Walkers tear down that wall.
In fact, I'll go as far to say that it will be the closing image of the season.
Not bad.
Wait just don't show all the shit that I got wrong.
I think next season will show the completion of Arya's Ark and her death.
Can't win them all.
With that said in case any of these educated shots in the dark end up being dead on for season 8.
Okay, first a quick update on the timeline.
Unconfirmed reports are saying that season 8 will begin shooting in October and last through August 2018.
Yikes that would mean the final season probably wouldn't air until 2019.
But that also means the scripts for season 8 almost certainly have not been written yet.
Yes the season has rumored to have been generally outlined at this point
But any leaked detailed plot summaries that claim to know
"Who says what to whom" in each scene are probably just fanfiction
Either way, it sounds like season 8 will be composed of six episodes, maybe each being like an 80 minute movie.
That's a lot of stories.
So let's start with my first prediction of what will happen during that season.
Cities will burn and they'll burn blue.
The night King and it's Dragon will continue on this path of destruction from the wall to lay waste to the major cities of Westeros
I mean guys
That's the promise the show made with these final images of season 7.
The wall falling is like a dam bursting. Nothing is safe.
And yeah...
The night King doesn't have any of the moral conscience that Daenerys has.
Like he doesn't need to win over the hearts and minds of Westeros.
He could just go about killing and converting them the old way.
Now as for where he'll go next...
Past episodes have given us a few hints like this season 7 premiere.
"If they breach the wall the first two castles in that Path are Last Herath and Karhold."
We've never seen Last Hearth and Karhold on the show before
So I feel like seeing them get destroyed wouldn't be too cathartic.
I feel like with six episodes left
They're gonna spin that visual effects money on new key and some more familiar places.
So actually let's look back at the last words that John spoke to Ed at Castle Black.
"Don't look at down while I'm gone."
Yeah, I think Castle Black might actually be the Night Kings next move.
Beyond that...
Things probably aren't looking too good for Winterfell
But I don't think it'll go down without a fight. More on that later.
Then also in season 6
Brans mysterious three-eyed raven visions
Included this shot of a dragon shadow over the roofs of King's Landing.
Now every other image from that vision was accounted for...
And even if this was a shadow of Daenerys dragons
When she recently arrived at the Dragonpit in last episode
I think we would have seen this shot
But we didn't.
So I think this shadow will end up belonging to the night Kings dragon as they destroyed King's Landing
This show has been teasing us with an attack on King's Landing since the beginning
Stannis's failed invasion.
All the recent preparations for the siege.
And I think the final act of Game of Thrones will turn this familiar sanctuary upside down.
Kinda like how the final battle of the Harry Potter series went down in the Hogwarts castle school
That would turn the Red Keep into that Harrenhal like ruin that Daenerys saw on her vision in season 2.
No, it wouldn't look exactly like that.
Because remember Cersei replaced that seven-pointed star window with a Lannister lion.
Actually, I think Daenerys vision was more metaphorical than literal
But this is a general idea.
The other city I think might burn is Oldtown.
Ebros and those other maesters seemed pretty arrogant about the threat of the White Walkers
"A crippled boy claims to have seen dead men on a march beyond the Wall"
"Thanks to the magical help of a raven with three eyes."
And archmaester Ebros probably shouldn't have places bet so firmly on the Wall.
"The Wall stood throughit all and every winter that ever came has ended."
Now in my past breakdowns
I pointed out how the citadel of Oldtown might be inspired by the ancient Library of Alexandria
Which famously burned along with countless sources of knowledge  about the ancient world.
So... I think it could be really fun to shut up these old maesters
With the shadow of the Night Kings dragon
Kind of like those old men playing chess in Independence Day
If King's Landing gets destroyed. What will that mean for Cersei?
Let's actually move on to my next prediction
Cersei will end tragically.
After going back and forth on Cersei
The ending of season 6 and 7 have pretty much stripped away all of Circe's moral finery
Down to something simple and true.
Cersei has no heart. She's Game of Thrones true human villain
And actually considering how closely Cersei's life has followed the prophecy she received as a girl
"The king will have twenty children. And you' will have three."
"That doesn't make sense."
"Gold will be their crowns."
"Gold."
"Their shrouds."
Yeah, I think there's a good chance Cersei's pregnancy won't come to term
And as sad as that would be and you know we really shouldn't wish for that to happen
A miscarriage would be one final thing that drive Cersei over the edge to become the Mad Queen
Now in our last breakdown Phillip and I discussed
How Cersei and Jamie's relationship was inspired by Shakespeare's tragedy Antony and Cleopatra
With Cersei as the complex Queen now -spoiler alert- for that 400 year old play
But in the end Cleopatra kills herself with the poison of an asp.
Remember in season 2 Cersei nearly poisoned herself
While sitting on the Iron Throne with Tommen Bracing for the end
I could see this mad Queen returning to that rock-bottom state
Refusing to let the White Walkers take her in the snowy ruins of the Red Keep.
It's also possible that the show will end up following through on that vow and quar theory
That Jaime will end up murdering his sister.
Now I went into Jaime's possible endgame in another video
But no matter what I think Cersei is clearly a tragic figure, but I could also see the show making
Her more of the main final villain that the heroes have to face not the night King.
I mean let's be honest we still don't know what the night King wants
And he'll maybe we'll never know like he could simply remain this iced zombie force of nature.
Now if that's the case maybe the show will kill him off early.
Now I know that could seem like a betrayal to the show
But really george RR Martin established this series as a political drama
grounded in real human conflict
Like martin has suggested that he wanted the Song of Ice and Fire to be different from the
Tolkien Lord the Rings model of a war for the fate of civilization in the future of humanity
And the hocking deaths of Ned Stark and Robb Stark and Catelyn Stark are all part of that.
George RR Martin intended actions to have consequences
Anyone can die and, yeah, that goes for characters we identify as pure heroes
And maybe the characters we identify as pure villains.
That said I do think Game of Thrones, the series, has evolved past that
In these recent seasons at least, becoming more of a series driven by divine intervention
I just think they're gonna ground it more than we expect and bring some of this supernatural
Mystery into the light and that leads me to my next prediction about the Night King
I think in the final season the Night Kings goal will be revealed
Not only that I think the show has already started to tell us.
Ok, so just like house season 5 began with a pre credits cold-open scene
Showing Cersei as a girl learning her prophecy
I predict season 8 will open with another flashback scene.
That gives us information about the other villain of the series the Night King
But in this case it'll be witnessed by Bran
Bran has already witnessed past events like the creation of the Night King,
The Tower of Joy, the wedding of Rhaegar and Lyanna.
There are actually a ton of other famous events I would love to see dramatized on this show
Battle of the Trident and the tourney at Harrenhal
But one essential memory to the wars to come could be...
The pact.
Now the pact was the peace agreement between the First Men and the Children of the Forest
Thousands of years ago.
It took place on the Isle of Faces.
The island covered in weirwood trees
on the Gods Eye lake in the middle of Westeros.
I think we're gonna see this and during the scene these ancient figures will explain what the night came once.
Revenge against the Children of the Forest for creating him and dooming him to a life of torment.
So we're gonna see them decide to build the wall to banish him north of the realm
Praying that he never gets powerful enough to break that seal, but yeah, he will.
I think we're also gonna see the Children of the Forest decide to hole up on this island
Because as the most recent episode made a point of clarifying
"Do they swim?"
"No."
"Good."
I actually think the decision to place John and his crew on this Island
In the middle of the frozen lake in episode 6
Was meant to visually foreshadow this location in the Gods Eye.
I think this was also foreshadowed by that scene in Episode 4.
With John and Danny in the cave on Dragonstone.
Remember they saw these cave paintings made by the Children of the Forest
With images of the children in the First Men together
And notice the two symbol side-by-side
I think the bisected circle represents the first men
Which could be why the White Walkers assembled human body parts in that pattern in the first episode
And I think the world spiral represents the Children of the Forest
Which is why we saw those stones laid out by the Children of the Forest in that shape in season 6
I think these markings were the children the forest record of the pack
And this is all setting up Bran witnessing the actual event in season 8
Also there was that moment in episode 5 when the maesters brought up the Children of the Forest
"Brings to mind the work of Jenny of Oldstones"
"The charlatan who claimed descend from the Children of the Forest."
I explained in that breakdown who Jenny of Oldstones is and her connection of the Children of the Forest
And the ghost of High Heart character from the books
And before I move on to my next prediction the reason we could even make this video because
We can't do all of these for free is because our friends at audible are sponsoring it so huge thanks to them.
Audible offers a wide selection of audiobooks and podcasts
And you could get a free audiobook with a 30-day trial by going to audible.com/newrockstars
I actually was reminded of Jenny of Oldstones and the ghost of High Heart
While relistening to George RR Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire series on audible
And a new title that I'm about to start to help organize my thoughts and theories
About the White Walkers and the Night King is Game of Thrones the book of White Walkers
Again, just check out audible.com/newrockstars or click on the link in the description below to start your trial today
Okay moving on to my next prediction
Let's talk about one of the biggest questions that finale left us with
What's next for the love birds of John and Daenerys now that John's about to learn that
He's actually Aegon Targaryen heir to the Iron Throne and Danny's nephew
I predict John and Danny will not end up together.
Okay. Stop crying. Was weird that you wanted them to be together.
I think the whole purpose of bringing these characters together was simply to produce a child.
The Song of Ice and Fire and that these two parents aren't really meant to grow old together;
When asked about how this series would end George RR Martin promised that it would be bittersweet.
Now I read that as while it may not be a straight of tragedy characters won't end up happily ever after.
And think about it Jon and Daenerys partnership has been mostly circumstantial
They're both young, leaders with aligned goals and obvious romantic chemistry
But there's no evidence that they have an emotional or platonic connection like  Ned and Catelyn had
Or even Jaime or Cersei have as toxic as that is.
Now I'm not certain if the news of Jon's Targaryen lineage will be the one thing to divide them
I'm sure it won't help but I don't think they're gonna outright turn on each other either.
Really, I just don't think both of them will survive the final season like I know they're the main characters.
It's just crazy to me that they've made it this far.
I think just like Jon's parents didn't survive that war to see their child grow up.
I think either John or Daenerys or both will leave this young Targaryen an orphan, okay?
I said stop crying.
I think that's why the recent finale episode shot their sex scene to be so dark and foreboding
With Tyrions concern reaction. I think we're meant to see the relationship as doomed.
Anyway... I'll come back to this.
Since we're talking about family members. Not really getting along here's another prediction.
I think season 8 will finally deliver a few brother against brother battles that they've been promising.
First, honestly, I didn't expect this until last episode, but I think we're gonna see the Hound vs.the Mountain.
Clegane Bowl. It's on brothers.
"It's not how it ends for you, brother."
"You know who's coming for you."
Also, second, I think it's inevitable that the dragons will fight each other as well.
Drogon and Rhaegal versus zombie Viserion.
I actually think that this battle will be the Battle of Winterfell that I alluded to earlier
An aerial battle between dragon brothers with Danny on Drogon, the Night King on Viserion and Jon on Rhaegal.
That's right. He's gonna be a dragon rider.
Specifically the dragon named after his father Rhaegar.
Meanwhile, in the south Cersei mentioned that Euron Greyjoy is bringing the golden company from Essos.
Along with their elephants
And I think the show is setting up this private army from Essos to collide with another private army from Essos
The Unsullied.
I guess that kind of makes them brothers. Not Really.
Now I would say the Unsullied had better chances in this battle.
You know with the fighting for love and all that.
But guys the golden company has freaking elephants. ELEPHANTS!
Now lastly among these battles between Family members
The finale made it clear that Theon Greyjoy is aiming to rescue his sister Yara
And, yeah, that Redemption plot puts them on a collision course with his uncle Euron.
Now in our breakdown we went into how the character of Euron
Might be inspired by Claudius from Shakespeare's Hamlet.
The murderous uncle who stole the throne, paranoid that his brothers ghosts will come back to seek revenge.
And I think that will happen in the form of little Theon.
Who like Hamlet could engage in a bloody scuffle that ends with both him and his uncle dead .
Now when we start talking about who will survive and who won't it gets a little hard;
It all depends on what kind of thematic tone the show will want to take in its final few episodes.
But I want to reward good moral characters by letting them survive
Or take a more cynical view and reward characters who are more dastardly and traitorous.
In George RR Martin's outline for the book series that he submitted decades ago
He originally planned for at least five main characters to survive over the end of the series
John, Danny, Tyrion, Bran and Arya.
Now a lot has changed since then the series went from a trilogy to seven installments
And I'm assuming Game of Thrones seasons 7 and 8 are gonna be pretty different from
The Winds of Winter and a Dream of Spring. So there's a good chance they won't stick to this.
And other than the death predictions I've already made in this video.
I'm gonna hold off on who lives and who dies for the rest of the cast.
I'll probably do another video on that but for now let's move on to the big question.
What will be the final scene?
Now the closing image of a television series is almost always a huge deal.
It's actually why we spend so much time in all of our breakdowns
analysing the themes and possible symbolism of each opening and closing image.
So what will be the final shot that we see before the credits roll on Game of Thrones? Will it be satisfying?
Now as I said before George RR Martin promised the ending would be bittersweet.
Some fans have speculated that the series will end by revealing all of these events are a story within a story
Written by Samwell Tarly as part of a new history manuscript of Westeros.
And back there was a scene this past season that might have hinted at that.
"What would you call it then?"
"Possibly something a bit more poetic."
Now the theory there was that Sam's future history book will be poetically titled A Song of Ice and Fire.
This would be similar to that moment in the Lord of the Rings movies when we see Bilbo Baggins manuscript
For There and Back Again, which is the exact story of The Hobbit.
It's also kind of like the final scene of the sitcom Roseanne.
Which featured her in a twist finishing a book that was actually just the fictional story
Of the final crazy season of that show.
Now I could see the final season of Game of Thrones hinting at this possibility with Sam
Writing all these events in a book, but I don't think it'll be the final image.
So here's my prediction.
The title of George RR Martin's plan seven book is a dream of spring
And just like the Winds of Winter was the title of the finale episode of season 6
I think a Dream of Spring will be the title of one of these season 8 episodes maybe the series finale.
So what does a Dream of Spring refer to?
Now someone suggested that all of the events from the books and the show could be a dream.
A vision in Brans mind with the final shot of the show being him waking up in his bed in Winterfell.
Honestly, I would hate that.
The only time that has worked was on the sitcom Newhart.
Which ended up waking up from a dream that was on the previous sitcom he was on.
Bob Newhart Show.
And I guess it also worked in that parody that Bryan Cranston did of that
With Breaking Bad all being a nightmare  from Hal the dad from Malcolm in the Middle.
I actually think a dream of spring could refer to John and Daenerys child
A winter baby who sleeps and dreams of the promise of spring.
And here's my out on the limb theory on this.
Imagine an end to Game of Thrones final season in which the Night King and Cersei are defeated
But Daenerys dies perhaps in childbirth leaving her baby to be cared after by John a.k.a Aegon Targaryen.
Who gently rocks his child to sleep as he or she dreams of spring
Or even bittersweeter.
Imagine both Daenerys and John have died.
Like maybe John won't have survived his one-on-one combat with the Night King
Which the show definitely seems to be setting up.
Instead this baby has to be cared after by another perhaps Samwell Tarly or Gilly
And the final image could be Sam singing a lullaby to lobe this baby to sleep
A Song of Ice and Fire.
Oh God that that's too violence, Sam. And that is not an appropriate story for a baby.
Or the bitter sweetest
Maybe the reason Daenerys would die in childbirth
Is because there's a complication with the pregnancy which would be a known risk with children
Who are the products of incest and the baby is revealed to be a dwarf.
That would leave Tyrion Lannister. Hand to the Queen and now King regent.
Looking after this orphaned child, a song of ice and fire who dreams of spring.
Too crazy? Yeah, probably.
We will have plenty of time to dream of spring between now and 2019
And make even more theory and prediction videos about what will happen to the likes of
Arya and the Hound and Jorah Mormont and Brienne
And GHOST! Where the hell is that direwolf been?
What do you think a dream of spring means?
Will Cersei or the Night King be the bigger villain in the final season?
And what do you think the Night King wants?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments below and tweet me directly @EAVOSS or @NEWROCKSTARS
Share this video and subscribe to new rockstars to see all of our many other Game of Thrones videos.
And if you want to help us make more videos you can contribute to us on patreon.
Big thanks to all of our donors. Especially Pony Stark.
Alright. Thanks for watching. Bye
Bye =)